nous sommes à l'école secondaire louis
riel une école publique francophone de
la région d'ottawa ici on forme entre
autres l'élite sportive et rares sont
ceux qui décrochent caleb lui était à
risque
il souffre de dyslexie je connais aucun
nom personnes avec une difficulté
davantage aussi forte que moi dans ma
classe j'ai pas décroché parce que j'ai
pu de la haine de l'école
en ontario il ya peu de jeunes qui
quittent l'école avant la fin de leur
secondaire le taux de diplomation dans
le réseau public et de 84% alors qu'au
québec qu'il est de 64%
les jeunes décrochent pas à nantes à
lyon on veut pas que les élèves et tombe
dans les tacles chaque élève vont avoir
un diplôme d'études secondaires ici
plusieurs mesures ont été mises en place
pour que les élèves atteignent cet
objectif comme ces équipes de la
réussite dont fait partie christina avec
deux autres enseignantes
l'équipe peut rencontrer les élèves
plusieurs fois par semaine selon leurs
besoins
il y suivre tout au long de leur
secondaire ici à l'école l'équipe de la
réussite on va trouver avec une élève
qui est un moyen qui est en deçà de 60%
ou qui prouve la difficulté à cumuler
tous ces critiques pour son diplôme mais
la recette du succès ontarien c'est plus
que ça en plus d'avoir des équipes de la
réussite dans chaque école secondaire
il ya notamment les maternelles quatre
ans et l'obligation de fréquenter
l'école jusqu'à 18 ans on est
responsable des élèves jusqu'à l'âge de
18 ans donc et les leviers pas le choix
et la seule école jusqu'à l'âge de 18
ans et puis on veut que tous les élèves
ont leur diplôme en dents de 4,1 sur les
500 élèves qu'on trouve ici à l'école
louis-riel l'an dernier il y en a 2 5
sont venus ici au local 155 parce qu'ils
avaient besoin dead dont plusieurs
avaient des difficultés d'apprentissage
j'aurais pas d aussi bonnes notes
jetterait un niveau beaucoup plus faible
évidemment je
pourrait pour réussir comme je réussirai
est ce que j'aurai des crochets sûrement
et la recette fonctionne depuis 10 ans
le taux de diplomation à crépy de 12
points de pourcentage en ontario mais ce
n'est pas sans effet la pression pour
réussir est forte selon sept chercheurs
lorsque les évaluations du ministère
arriver un niveau d'anxiété et les temps
chez les familles que chez le personnel
enseignant
je pense que la performance à outrance
et pas nécessairement bien non plus ce
qui bien de l'autre côté c'est qu'on
s'assure que tout le monde
nantes le note de passage en ontario et
de 50 pour cent au québec elle est de
60%
malgré cette différence le modèle
ontarien suscite de l'intérêt au québec
mais certains ont des réserves
moi je crois peu campus et porter un
modèle d d'une province à l'autre à 10
ans si ça marche chez eux ça va marcher
chez nous changeront d'attitude par
rapport à notre réseau ayons un
gouvernement qui dit crois qu'ils
arrêtent kiki qui ne jouent pas au yoyo
avec les structures mais qui cherchent
davantage à mobiliser les acteurs qui
veulent s'impliquer en éducation
caleb lui est sur le point de terminer
ses études à l'école louis riel
il a maintenant l'intention d'aller à
l'université et de surmonter encore une
fois ces difficultés d'apprentissage
[Musique]